hey there are you an aspiring motion
designer that's eager to make a
significant leap in your career this
year but tired of going it alone done
with sifting through course after course
yet still feeling stuck trust me you're
not alone and you're in the right place
I invite you to join the collective
where we turn lonely learning Journeys
into Collective victories the collective
offers the resources and professional
mentoring you typically find at an elite
design school but at a fraction of the
cost whether you're struggling to bring
your Design Concepts to life start your
career or simply start your journey in
motion design the collective is tailored
to help you reach those milestones and
so much more I'm Cameron Peron and I've
been navigating the world of motion
design for over 25 years partnering with
industry Giants along the way I know the
roadblocks you might be facing and I've
created the collective to offer you the
mentorship and Community I wish I had
when I started as a member of the
community here's what you're unlocking
Community Forum don't just get feedback
get quality input from create who are as
passionate as you are weekly coaching
and mentoring courses are great but
personalized coaching that's a game
changer we don't just focus on your
technical skills we're here to guide you
through the maze that is the motion
design career landscape monthly live
workshops stay current with workshops
led by industry experts Master new
techniques and stay ahead of the curve
creative challenges these aren't your
run-of-the-mill exercises they're
designed to push your creative
boundaries and get you recognition
within the community work reviews and
critiques bring your best and let's make
it better our critique sessions are
designed to refine your portfolio and
set you up for Success so you've got a
choice continue on the solo path or jump
into a community that's got your back
with the collective you're not just
saving time and money you're investing
in a network and mentorship that will
catapult you to the next level don't let
another year pass you by make this the
moment your motion design career truly
takes off I hope to see you inside the
collective